всі
добрий вечір тут якийсь запис
добрий вечір дорогі обіцяв я готовий сиджу
правда у такому форматі
у їжі та сподіваюся вам буде цікаво і я
зможу відповісти на ті питання, які ви
поставте і хотів би почати з тих
питань, які вже були заздалегідь
відправлені на сайт відверто говорять
те кожне питання це стільки ось
стільки укладено що відповіді короткі
дуже важко буде давати ну наприклад я
з криму
у нас кажуть, що нами вже пожертвували
задля домовленості путіна з або
вселенському крим визнають росії а натомість
особлива донбас щось знаєте як ви
безвісна це спочатку при окупації
крима і по 100 як почалася війна на
Сході загалом для всіх було
очевидним, що путін намагається тим самим
де фокусує увагу з крима і тим
самим
переконливі аргументи уявити
світовій спільноті що крим не варто не
буде ніколи обговорювати
це фланг павутиння і загалом ми з вами
спільними зусиллями до сьогодні і я
впевнений далі, як успішно ламали
його плани які поні neapolitan
підступний і дуже-дуже як їм здається
прочитаними
крим сьогодні загалом є темою
номер один на міжнародними
міжнародні майданчики тому що це
настільки очевидним є
ось такий злочин
21 століття коли військовим шляхом захопили
чужу територію і тут же за законами
росії анексували
що ну з ким би ми не зустрічалися усі
ці роки і ось коли я вийшов із в'язниці
ніхто не готовий сьогодні якимось чином
спускати це путін інша справа що
останні наші зміни тут вже в
україні риторика на жаль змінилася
і таких категоричних мідь ми сочі як
які були раніше
і вони звучали з вуст насамперед
головнокомандувача як я називаю
полководця нашої країни порошенка та
звичайно ж його команди
це мід ми сочі були дуже сильні чотки
та безапеляційні
що ми україна вважає росію
злочинцем вважає військовим агресором
і покарання має бути неминучим і не
тільки санкції зараз у таких
а так і 1 кладений які вірніше не
гаслом з ВІЛ був озвучений президентом
порошенка це 17 року, бо я вже
тоді був в Україні що без криму не
відбудеться незалежна держава
Україна це дуже глибокий і дуже
такі ось очевидні для всіх хто бореться
за україну
очевидним є фактор і тому
незважаючи на ці зміни ось останні
події показали, що народ з цього народу
України
ніколи не забуде крим мало того зараз
коли повітря і запевнила таким
настроєм скажемо так такими ось
тривогами що можуть розміняти ось
цього активності ось це ось реакція
українського народу вона стала більшою
категоричної та
звучить голосніше тому у мене ось після
останніх подій після акції не
капітуляції десятки десятки тисяч людей
та сльози
впевненості такі зростала коли говорили про
тому що ми обов'язково повернемо крим
тому носити його шляхи не зійдемо
імплементація формули штайнмайєра стало
причиною масштабної акції не капітуляції
чому наше суспільство так бурхливо реагує
якоюсь мірою я вже відповів на цей
питання тому, що нещодавно у мене був
розмова з представниками
фракції слуга народу, і я їм намагався
дохідливо донести деякі спроби
досягнення світу поступками путіну форми
шва формула штайнмайєра для мене
тери формула путіна
чреваті і навіть не короткостроковими
якимись скажу результатами які
потім можна суспільству втюхати на самому
справі дуже серйозні сподіваюся вони мене
почули про те, що далі буде
концентрація
такого хаосу та розбрату всередині країни та
не секрет зараз на мій погляд ми не
тільки на мій погляд досить активно
ось ці кілька місяців актив
активізувалися такі проросійські
настрої та їх парами називаю чого вже
там відбирати вираз тому що дуже
всього
наочно відбувається коли у тебе по
столиці
твоєї країни розгулюють так звані
російські журналісти які і не
приховують своїх поглядів щодо
тому що Україна
російські і про те, що вони бачать україну
як частина
смола з готелі там колонією Росії ви
постійно ходіть на майдан що кажуть
люди буде 3 на буде 3 майдан ось у
останній останній ця акція не
капітуляції коли у мене на душі на
одному з каналів запитали
я сказав я бачив обличчя людей які не
тільки йдуть а ось які під узбіччя
стоять до цього уявіть там
відстані десь близько на три
кілометрів від парку шевченка до якщо так
ось я не помиляюся 03 може трохи більше
ось якщо
прийшли
десятки тисяч колони це десятки тисяч
стояли узбіччя і про ті проспекти так
ось розумієте я дивився на людей які
кричали дякую йому хоч я думаю що це
відноситься і до них самих тому що вони
вище і сльози та оплески але не були
ні
це сльози були того, що знаєте коли ти
впевнений перед тобою відбувається подія
яке дає тобі впевненість і силу та
від цього ти плачеш але це не сльози com
відчай лечу
або ще чогось тому 3
майдан це залежить звісно наскільки
готова нова влада
резидент особисто тому, що сьогодні влада
це концентрація води фуко
президента наскільки він готовий і надалі
харчуватися
[музика]
не чути як що говорить народ
апелювати до такого відсотка
які він отримав на виборах і рахувати
що це більшість народу України на
мій погляд це може виявитися
трагічна помилка для нього самого
потужність розуміє головний ми switch цих
акцій але якби не розуміла, то не було
б останньої заяви на мінській
групі де точок пішла який поставив
підпис
разом з іншими чітко заявили, що
вимога про те, що перед тим як
політичні
відбуватимуться заходи на активно
територіями
то мають бути забезпечують захід
безпеки тільки тобто висновок
російських військ розформуванні лнр днр
повний контроль на всій території
місія обсі по всій межі або каски
міжнародна місія і тільки тоді
нашим законам і під нашими під скажемо
так під за участю безпосередньо з
центральної влади можуть пройти
такі вибори загалом як і по всій
країні Україні
але ось особисто моя думка я думаю що не
дуже це розуміють нова команда що
значить проводити вибори на цій
території ті хто там живуть розуміють що
за ці роки ось є таке поняття
відчуженість від реальності в якій
зараз саме край ось така вільно і
незалежно може десь навіть у якійсь
ступеня абстраговано я проблема відведення
від тієї ситуації, яка в криму на
сході України на перших територіях та
більше страху у свідомості не потрібно
якийсь час на мій погляд це мінімум
років п'ять плюс п'ять років окупації 5 років
на те, щоб люди могли звільнитися від
того страху там тиск від того ось а
то й абстраговано sti від ситуації на
вільні частиною України і лише тоді
можна буде щось
[музика]
щось таке ось свобода волі вияву
вільне коли людина сама зможе
ухвалити рішення чому росія в кому так
активно бореться проти кримських татар
спочатку була я ще тоді не сидів
чотирнадцятий рік ось ця вся активна
ситуація перед окупацією дещо
тижнів
кінець і потім означає марк місяць спроби
з нами домовитися прозвучало таке від
сухої його команди такий ось така
формулювання кримські татари не договір
врятую
не договірні тобто взагалі то це так
називається насправді мені просто
відмовилися ходити в якісь ось такі
домовленості
маючи великий досвід боротьби з
свою батьківщину ми приблизно вже тоді
уявляли що нас чекає і яким шляхом
ми йтимемо я на одній із зустрічей
ось наповнилася адміністрації президента
путіна приїжджали вони намагалися
приблизно уявити мені картини
того, що відбуватиметься тут криму в
випадку внесли якщо не зможуть кримські
татари домовитися з москвою
але це така картина напевно здавалося у
загалом
лінію поведінки і там але за цим всім
відчувалася жорстокість
терор я тоді їм сказав що ви нас
погано знаєте і ми не візьмемо ми не будемо
озброєні зібрати чи не робити тому
що мирне населення і може в такій
ситуації як озброїтися та надавати
військові опори на жаль
у перевантажуючи і так званої армії у
нас у криму і
райські спецпідрозділи та 6 не
виконала своїй присязі і я сказав що у
нас є в арсеналі такі методи
радянський союз один не впорався, а ви не
що радянському союзу мілан так нудити
будемо що ви дуже пошкодуєте про те, що в
прям увійшли так от думаю що через п'ять
років не досягнувши результату крім
збільшення агресії у такій ситуації
нічого не варто очікувати, бо
кримські татари і до нього ж примикає
дуже великі групи не кримських
татар нашого червоного україни в Криму
такій ситуації потрібно звичайно вони дуже
сильно розраховувати на Україну та на
світова спільнота україна повинна
повернутися до того вектора
чітких твердих ми сочі і на адресу Росії
це у свою чергу буде знову наших
союзників мобілізувати
на підтримку нас місяць тому арка понти
провели кому місцеві вибори таким
чином вони ж намагаються мікс ліги
робити свою владу до цього відноситься це
вже п'ятий на мою вибори майже троє з
них проходили
коли я був у в'язниці але тенденція
до того що опір має різну
форму звичайно але при цьому воно
збільшується і відсоток участі наших
громадян задали всіх кримських татар усі
стає дуже очевидним і чому я
говорю незважаючи
різні форми опору тому що
тут важливо те, що наші громадяни не ходять
ці вибори незважаючи на погрози та на
репресії на те, що
катається якимось чином під розпис і
брати там коротше
друкарів і відсоток все одно не
вдається вище 30 показати незважаючи на те
що за нашою інформацією більше
півмільйона з Росії завезли коли
касьян
і ясна річ у першу чергу вони будують
цей злочин я не назву це
по-іншому і росія ставить завдання що в
цьому злочині брали участь ось такий
принцип кутової поруки щоб і місцеві
які проголосувавши природно порушивши
усі закони у тому числі закони україни
одночасно сприяє стають
співучасниками
ліги мотивувати це політичний
процес і природно завдання через такі
політичні процеси владу ось цю
окупацію
закону але не буде я так думаю
конфіскував тенденція тільки
збільшується опір
ви по на 3 роки сиділи у в'язниці ще була
на його шия і близько невиразний вид роботи
одним словом це не скажеш тут
сукупність факторів поперся з ринку
людей народу україни кримсько-татарського
народу і через
збувалося така ринку я весь світ віддам
саспенс тва а коли я зв'язку зв'язковий цр
дуже ще не приїхала
привезли мене
ми не ми не в Києві я часто таке питання
не йшов
чому як я витримав і деякі такі
мужність героїзм я сказав мені було
соромно коли мені пропонували деякі
паскудні угоди я правда не було дуже
соромно, що я якимось чином піддамся
ось ці нелюдською умовою було
звичайно дуже вони вміють це робити
хотілося б строго цього позбутися але
що скаже народ про мене що скаже мої
моїм дітям
мої руки і ось це давало ще більше не
зусиль що краще стоячи померти ніж
принизити себе і чому ви відкриваєте
порошенка я вам відверто скажу я це
ще говорив у в'язниці я поважаю людину
поважаю за вперше я сказав це мій
президент коли я бачив як його
ненавидять мої вороги це було у в'язниці
це ось розумієте де ти можеш просто
відмовчатись тому що так простіше потім
сидіти і заявити в обличчя їм, що ти
поважаєш людину, яка для них ворог
це звісно
треба було розуміти на які наслідки
собі прирікаєш але на те вона і є
позиція щоб не виляти не
пристосовуватися навіщо тоді сів у
в'язницю міг би до цього прокляття другові
може і пощастило майка і пронесло ви
далі коли я бачив їхні агресії
ось таке знаєте ось такий відчай
вони часто приїжджали будь-які комісії з
Москви не і генерали та полковники різні
комбезе ось вони не приховували своєї
ненависті до того що що таке як
порошенко означає а очолює хупи та
так далі а ось коли звільнився то ось
цей
путінське гасло будь хто тільки не
порошенко фактично давав у відповідь все на
питання хто хто сьогодні та вчора для
країни добре як президент як
полководець як лідер я думаю що я
впевнений у цьому, що його роль дуже вся ще
попереду для нашої країни, бо
сьогодні ось у цьому політичному житті я
бачу що альтернативне немає і людина
не рушив хоча міг і має все
можливості але він продовжив свою
свою політичну політичну боротьбу
ясному і
message для України та для путіну що все
що для нього головним україном а той
знаєте гасло україна понад
і що боротиметься й надалі за Україну
за українську дорогу
нібито обирає кася працювати на d
окупацію криму chanell та європейської
солідарності стратегія стратегія
звичайно 1
цей окупація крила і в різних
політичних групах по-різному називають
це вони говорять коли повернеться крим
інші кажучи повернути крим ми говоримо
європейська солідарність порошенка
ми говоримо про слабо динку і ось ось від
цього і
вже шляхи
які коли ти кажеш звільнимо
клімату це сила України має бути
відповідна
і всередині країни це мається на увазі і
армія та мобілізації суспільства навколо а
звільнення криму це і звичайно ж
підтримка наших громадян у Криму та
звичайно від комплексу цих мер світ набагато
легше і має підтримку у світовому
спільноті ніж коли ти несеш месич
що крим повернеться путін здохне ще що
то там станеться чи ще якось
станеться і ось знаєш якимось там
шляхом навіть там до абсурду доходить що у
нас будуть хороші пензе рівень розвитку
буде добрий і ось значить там все раптом
передумають вони кинуть права по-перше
крим не давали думати референдуму так
такого не було злочин під
автоматом під військами російської Росії
російської держави і думати не
даючи я сам там був що ось коли ти
тому що або
відкритими до визначають своє ставлення
криму але звичайно ж це взагалі то
мандрівникові та тому завдання звільнити
крим все інше ось ті шляхи під нього
пішов а звільненню над україною самою
до цього прагне сила армії вона
продемонструвала сайті роки коли
зупинила такого жахливого жахливого
силою агресора який що там казати
Європа побоюється
україна сьогодні на передньому плані
показала Європі що таке в 21 столітті
зуміти тобто має такий народ що
готовий ціною свого життя стати на захист
свободи незалежності України, а не
думати тільки у бізнес інтересів
економічних зв'язках і тоді
тому є у нас чітке бачення та
останні кілька років ось та виборів у
загалом
успішність цієї стратегії було очевидним
тому раз я сюди вклала всі сили і
облягала my у тому числі на хід виборів а
як росії вміє впливати я думаю що тут
всі повинні розуміти якщо америку
колошматять цих скандалів втручання
Росії їх не вибір або у Великобританії
коли я питання prix обіцяли ви на
верховній раді жебрацтві яка взагалі
це ваша роль там що ви можете зробити
я не вважаю що ми у меншості
я не вважаю щоб ось у такому розумінні
опозиції по-перше у себе вдома у своїй
країні по-друге у нас дуже так за нами
не просто найактивніша частина ми самі
є тією частиною активною частиною
цього товариства які за ці роки
показало наскільки вона може змінювати
україну і я думаю що ось якраз ми
впевнені в собі і своїх силах впевнений і
тому що ми частини цього самого
активного суспільство
яка наша роль
ну іноді б не демонстрували
Верховна Рада я навіть спілкуючись з мономер
шістьма з представниками щоразу
кажу, щоб вони не обдурилися ось на ту
на ту демагогію що там 73 відсотки або
ще що те що це все ілюзії захисту
ціною тебе від депутата лише народ
більше ніхто і народ сам може
визначити свою долю надалі
тому ми намагаємося свою
волю виконувати так, щоб ці
наміри реваншизму про тих ось
тривог, які відчуваємо in і ось активна
частина народу щоб вплинути на
влада і не допускати критичності
як ви бачите останнім часом нам у
низці випадків
крем перейшов у росію без мила я зараз
стану миру та спокою чому ви
проти того, що без і ленінський
домовився з путіним і настав світ
україни ну ось це ось та маніпуляція
яку дуже активно росія використовує
україні на міжнародному майданчику та
тут теж я чую цих людей які
намагаються разом такі хочеться якийсь
гарячі слова обмежусь тій немає рівної
яку несуть якщо ти не хочеш бачити про
тому що росія тисячі тисячі тисячі
людей
вбила на твоїй території років не тільки
воїни
які захищають свою країну це і без
провини загалом громадяни не військові
сидять сотник в'язницях викрадені десятки
деяких тільки ми знайшли по-звірячому вбиту
міа долі інших взагалі нічого не
у криму ніхто сьогодні
не відчуває безпеки життя якщо ви
не хочете цього виду то навряд чи він які
то докази
можна донести домовлятися з
путіним взагалі це ілюзія і з Росії
домовлятися і те ж саме протягом
сотень років
показані чим закінчуються закінчується
окупацією і ти опиняєшся від колонії
для Росії приват банку по суті
держави україни виграв апеляцію
лондонському суді у суперечці з колишніми
власниками ігорем Коломойським мікени
in 1 богом
що це означає для України ось я думаю
що
коломойський і він не залишить спроб на
цьому він вже якось сказав що
якщо так важливий приватбанк для України
питання вирішуване тобто ви кладете
грошовим тобто це людина що у
загалом далекий від таких понять як бути
членом не те слово вибрав бути
громадянином цієї країни пишається цією
країни і боротися за цю країну і все
вимірюється грошима це його вибір
те, що сьогодні європейські інституції
валютний фонд
досить у cayenne сказали що це
дуже сильна білда і знайти нашу країну
це очевидно я не дмуха не раджу
президенту
ленському та його команді сьогодні навколо
цього питання яким чином
спекулюватимуть у панамі будуть
розслідувати справу проти кравця за
помилкові свідчення проти порошенка чому
у цій ситуації кам'янська пропофол
розібрав за два місяці додати мед та
там і є політичні причини
очевидне вчора президент порошенка
своєму коментарі до ухваленого закону щодо
8 жахливий висловив нашу спільну думку про
тому що зміни до закону
настільки роблять керованим судову
систему що таких рішень
міжнародних
судів європейських країн довгий
звернення до панамських судів буде частим
що не дає мені влади, як ви молодші
колеги з фракції у вас хороша команда
я не приховую якщо до виборів я бачив по
заслугам і оцінював за тим, як ми
спілкувалися як ми їздили по всій Україні та
як приймали люди люди народ і я кожен
раз із захопленням сприймав це і з
великою повагою нашій команді, а зараз
я ще й коли бачу наскільки вони
професійні це знаєте це не
просто слова нам часто ці
поправки та законопроекти рук перед
день прийняття видавали і наші
професіонали і протягом кількох там
буквально може лише 20 хвилин встигали
проаналізувати і настільки чітко
формую формулювали
нашу позицію що я кажу що я пишаюся
і я чесно вам скажу дуже сильно
заздримо і намагаючись
українську мову розпочато
флауї бобовий
виконати та й намагаюся наскільки
товарів можна не буду тут щось
вигадувати наскільки можливо намагаюся
враховувати а потім турборежима він тобі не
дає можливість хтось треба бути
професіоналом щоб
лічені там годинники орієнтуються у всіх
цих змін і наскільки вони небезпечні
для сторони давати відповідну
реакцію фракції які ціни в буфеті
верховної ради
чорні прекрасні ігри нема я сам навіть
жартував 1 днів казав що мабуть цей
період ви не застали це жарт xml
мабуть дешевше ніж десь у кафе
місті
ну і немає такого вибору та вишукування я
іноді говорю що про що не нагадує
період таких ось радянських їдалень
я там кілька разів обідав.
[музика]
щось з рибою кави тієї яка
я загалом намагаюся по можливості в
кримсько-татарських кафе пити заварне
кави на честь такого нема там тому що
робити звичайний автомат більше нічого
такого ж чорт можна було б розповідати
у вас залишилися рідні в круглих там не
переслідуйте за ваші акції у мене все те
не діти багато хто з
батько 83 роки там і не це достатньо
складно дається я коли згадав я коли
мене везли цим спецбортом разом із помер
я ж фірмові
розібрали я їх не бачив три роки нікого
з них багатьох поховав вірніше ховав
народ поки сиділа і маму мою теж і
тітки мої дядьки а мамині і по батьківській
боці але я коли вже конкор та
підлітали коли там видно було
черга а черепичний дах у цих спеців
запитав я можу нам дали мені просто
сказали це від вас залежить тобто я
розумів що повинен vx літак та на
прес-конференції, яка там зібралася
сказати подякувати ердогану путін за
свою звільнений хочу деякі так і
я я прийняв інше рішення я знав
що ціна цьому рішенню мої
моя неможливість бути у себе вдома
впливати у в'язниці боровся знав що ми крим
звільнимо я ще з борюся і знаю що крим
ми звільнимо якщо переслідування ну
прізвища вона дається взнаки
родичам name одразу з роботою
довелося попрощатися загалом цей етап
типова ситуація
для всіх кримських татар храмі ми в 4
українську мову життя комісія цех яко
за волі ваші вставлені стало не до за
кому-кому готові shushi державна доля
fci мої напрацювання обшуку в так 3 вашому
і ти хто врятував пікулі
спекулює спекуляція спекулює на
все це не сцени вважаючи до України до
української мови і і для мене для мене
особі я зараз уроки
правильно уроки ліру
[музика]
дивом of 4
я кощія за раз читаю
[музика]
намаєшся розмелювання
розбуду стиснуті корейської мовляв і я був
ескалації
я придумає ведж і спілкування було
автономії
особливого статусу українці чому бавовни
статусу ситуація з окупацією я поважаю
автономія кабула вона була російська
автономію коли та автономію рублів такі
у мису намір бог за раз за 1 цент
особливий статус з нашої батьківщини на
якісь наяки відкривав тепер більше було
більше красу
руки була наша держава
тому за раз у ball мова
україни c право кримсько-татарського
народу зупинити і
автономія обидва ласкаво буду
кримськотатарської національні та c ючі
дасть
бо то шансів на окупацію тому що це
повідай а міжнародному праву і як я
кажу що треба забити цвях на всіх
міжнародних майдан чеках цим статусом
зміною україна має цей бій
забити
щоб і не тільки путін та та macron та
Меркель та інші навіть не намагалися
висмикувати не і не змогли, бо
це право священне і вона захищена і
закріплена всіма міжнародними нормами
закону
дружині може вивести на я на еблище на і
майбутньою перспективою взвод викликало мені
кримсько-татарських замочено рахунок
знаходяться [ __ ] лише там у криму то
кинь її за нинішню гладу
це можливо
а ти шлях за раз капелюшок кіно гуркотить
сьогоднішня влада
на не пам'ятають він не дали гарантії товщу
бутіки та сценарії звали не наші
наручників заражаючи путін путін у путина
сотні арештовує саджати у в'язницю і ми
за ці кілька днів отримали нових
політичних в'язнів за тими ж
мотивів
що наприклад звільнили балуха чи мене
тому я бачу я в пера вважаю що це
є боротьба твоя як громадянина як
людину це боротьба має на увазі
[музика]
що ти потрапиш потрапити форму тому
або ти заповнюєш свій обов'язок і знаєш
що на тебе чекає або ти виїжджаєш і
намагаються убезпечити себе так о 6
вирішила по-іншому і люди вони не не не
ставлять ті, що потрапили за свою боротьбу
у в'язниці
щоб же звільняли від будь-якої ціни не й
я не вважаю правильним, що сьогоднішня
влада через це намагається робити
основним фактором того, як вона як вона
досягає результату ми повинні
підписати форму цього шайтана і потім
значить ми отримаємо натомість
нам звільнять наш фріда шайтан я маю
президента путіна до якого має на
окупованих територіях мільйони
наших громадян на цих територіях знову
набирає цей обмінний матеріал тут
потрібно більш чітко та жорстко діяти та
мобілізувати навколо себе світове
спільнота і щоб я останнім часом
наприклад не чув про з боку влади
сьогоднішні про те, що на
збільшувати санкції проти Росії потрібно
вести до того, щоб ці самці
збільшувалися а зараз ми більше
переживаємо за те, що там з історія sc
махом для когось здавалося що вона
пройде непомітний ми тепер бачимо
наслідки тепер ухвалено рішення про те
що будуть розслідування відносин
україни а як як як на що
розраховували що ми злочинця що
винний у смерті ні в чому неповинних
близько 300 чоловік жінка
ми віддати чи нам скаже правильно
зробили
плануєте ви відвідати сушіння область
так я постарався за цей рік багато де
побувати і дуже люблю щиро дуже
люблю їздити Україною
я дуже сподіваюся я зараз планую на початку
листопада там у нас є тимчасові рамки не
я собі це можу дозволити взяти своїх
друзів аллаха 2 когось ще про там
фотографував хто бути вільний і про
їздити знову те культурне по Україні
я і так ось відкрите багато щиро
кажу що народ дуже-дуже з великим
повагою і якщо таке знаєте
таким ось відкритим почуттям кохання
ставляться до людей, які борються за
україну бах уже підтвердив, бо
вона підтвердить хто в цей момент у кілі
я думаю, що обов'язково без міністр
закордонних
справ зграйка за і весь народ я хочу миру
у режиму
соцвиплати яхти і не 150 ось таких але я
все ще вважаю, що це не його
компетенція робити такі заяви для цього
я зміню міністр оборони
є прем'єр є президент частина
останніх заявку при стійкій я взагалі
вважаю що в таких ви по тк рф повинна
лягти заява ось про відставку крім я ось
прибираю всюди спекуляцію некомпетентності
так далі ось у цьому конкретному
заяву ах там покладу його випадково
навіщо мені це дав мені
а де немає на запитання третина
дякую за всі теплі слова що у не
кажете за раз я вершина це не хочемо я
кожному відпишуся виского у мене такий
питання
цілям і селян алімів селі моряком авто
світовим не те було опитування в Україні на
цей день велика чисельність gpl з 2
скрина який стикається з правління
діти, які залишаються на території
вільної україни не знають жодної
чи планується відкриття школу з і
значень української мови
ми це питання обговорюємо, є у нас
така дуже хороша організація
[музика]
прекрасна
патріотка та активна якої вона нікому
не дає хвилини спокою
наша курсі цього так я правда це я
щиро кажу я радий, що вона нам нікому
спокою не дає ми знову фокусів намагаємось
зараз працювати софія стара коні ми
можемо у нас дроти 3 у вас натуральної
санкції проти Росії але які ми
набираємось цру б ти
такому нас теж часто брат упустила
броні косинець зварив і
зате ще й так звані випадки
торгівлі Росії згадувалося досі до цього часу
годину а за раз не таке виправлення вірусу
проекти ядерний довга назва та все
пазли пазл дозволило сьогодні купувати у
Росії електроенергії що взагалі звичайно
викликало великий резонанс у суспільстві
особливо в кров у колах фахівців
ми країна які за останні ось цей
ось рік на сотні мільйонів доларів
експортували
електроенергію тобто заробляли а за
раз на догоду одному олігарху
якого всі озвучують 7 відомі
коломойський означає голова комітету
вніс цю поправку йому наб'ю зараз
проголосувало гі і не чуючи аргументів
опонентів ось хто ж потім якщо ми самі
це дозволятимемо робити нас війна
йде хіба потім ми зможемо
мобілізувати навколо цього наших
партнерів та вимагати вимагає дано
вимагаємо, щоб сам все збільшувалися
проти Росії china не перенесли дату
великого шляху до вашого звання за завданням
катаєва лізою один нічого виконати
погана
а народ славиться це така тривожно ми а
не розумієте я ніколи питає чесно
відповідаю я точно знаю ще там коли я
знаходився в руках я слухав усі ці
сценарії повірте не далеко не від
останніх людей і я вже опинившись у
районі схвалив наплювати путіну на
залізницю та
йому цікавиться україни україну можна
взяти тільки через будинок тому якщо я
даю цьому звіт, то звичайно ж хотілося
щоб сьогоднішня влада чуйніше
ставилася до цих тривог, які всі
більше більше зростають
серед народу
і ось та заява що там нехай
готується ми
та сила яка на конструктиві яка
намагається донести від занепокоєння народі
якісь раз присутність али коли влада
не буде з чю ти зайве
люди будуть виходити і на майдани та абу
влада прислухається і буде все звалиться і
ще Україна була сильною успішною та дала
тисяч прагу і було знову такі на такому
мало такого
був і куполах у як там у європейської спи
ноти європейських лідерів обидві влади
я українці і таке звучне таки
слова ладу жити буде як буде так
чи буде у нас уповноважений з прав
кримсько-татарського народу
небезпечно єдині останні зустрічі
яке сталося до цього питання
піднімався статут від продажу
кандидатуру представив і ця кандидатура
рефат чубарів
я загалом не зовсім
я не проти такого такого інституту, але я
проти, щоб його очолював голова
меджлісу кримськотатарського народу тому
що цей статус я вважаю більш як
сказати не незалежний рівень такий
моїм Господь і сприйняття як рівень
президентський чотирнадцятому році вже немає
у 15 м році коли ми стала призначили
уповноваженим то були
то були такі умови та обставини
коли це було дуже важливі та потрібні
рішення тому що заважали був
деморалізовані якоюсь мірою був
дуже сильно обмежений можливостях на
території криму пішли посадки перші так
а потім заборона і це було ось знаєте це
була ніби париже дія за раз я
вважаю що ти маєш бути на нього винен
очолити шановні або скажімо так
розуміє конструкторську тематику в
криму сприймається
суспільством і представлений
мрії сумки мтс татарського народу
я сказав своє не можливо
кримськотатарська автономія
на ганчірочок від і повернули
я сказав що ще я поважаю та повернули
а викликали так
ЗМІ на ланки статус статус
статусу кримська на кримськотатарській uav
тонометр автомат свої
таке серйозним інструментом як я вже
вище сказав ось питанні
звільнення злі мови стверджують що
ви отримали в кому російський паспорт це
правда ніколи не брехав не люблю це
робити і три роки доводив так
звану долю що мені вішати ваш
російський паспорт не треба у вас є на
голову відбиті боксери та алкоголіки
departe ось їм роздавайте я
принципово не брав і сказала що я
буду останній кримський татарин який
візьме російський паспорт і навіть коли
у в'язниці були пропозиції що отримати
паспорт це дуже сильно змінить моє
стан тобто з кого їм це на
свободу та інші посилок чи там
пропозиція дуже серйозна я сказав ні
і ось тут я розповісти скажу як
тепер коли мені зачитували вирок так
званих у голова верховного
суду криму перші слова були такі
чагас артизі тулаїв громадянин україни я
почав плескати
я намагаюся в камері було поряд була
дружина так захисницею
полоза я став аплодувати дачу мене не
цікавило і дружина міллер чому
радіє тобі вісім років далі я
сказав ні взагалі не цікаво я вже
переміг тому що всі три роки а судів
був близько 200 мене називали громадянин
росії та україни
я щоразу зробив заяву та
наполягав на тому, що я громадянин України
ах ти треба поставте
харчування верховної ради корисливі бані
раз вода або як енергія ці народної
добрий будинок того, чому ми наповнили
стикуватися світом подаєте
паркану міг народу а самі не може трусити
світло народне добро розумієш це народу
чун ці ​​люди особливо до околиці потреб і
у тому числі і від народної ти мільярди а
коханим добра пораджуся у фракції у
якому це має бути вигляді тобто яка
форма тобто а паспорт не отримувала не
збираюсь вид нашого
президента не маятника реакції на
кримський ударятися меджліс
кримськотатарського народу дробиш так у
заяву
тут ще ту-ту реакцію і вже радіальну
кричав їм всю ситуацію з каналу та spread
будемо якира меншим і за
[музика]
створила жити прямо ти так ось ти раніше
такі провокації збоку росії bull і
а не прав і тому шукає оптом і bull і
У процесі кожного 1 біт України нам уже
у цьому допомагала ми йому хтось допомагав і з я
хто випав а ось метання стукіт for honor
дипломатичним щілинам молодець та
ризиковий shell та шлях це нікель пікові
піску зброєю заходять і стріляє це
демонстрація мощі армії та дипломатії все
це разом є місті пеппа,
сьогоднішнього дня міжфракційна бідними
кубани з кубанці я україни
скажи для там 414 rocket бафф колег не
пускав і ми з батьківщини на кубані
чи залишилися там пожував їх ціль акція
кубань
c україна там теж багата з особиста до
таїнству харчування сьогоднішня так скажемо
у вічка чубу доктринальне амністія для
учасників бойових та на сході ukraine
[музика]
nice якому разі
злочинці вбиваючі вбиваючі наших
людей вбиваючі не повинні вони повинні
понести покарання і для цього ми з вами
будемо дуже довго за цим стежити я
кладу на кичі від криму та україни плани
для членства на те я не думаю я у цьому
переконаний і знову-таки заява що нас
там ніхто не чекає неприпустимо зелінського
ми повинні їм і як європейській
солідарності робимо все можливе щоб
отримати це подання і прискорити ці
процеси як ви знаєте президент
порошенко нещодавно була на асамблеї з
нато і дуже вбрання ритейлери
обговорював усі ці моменти та отримав
високу оцінку за ті п'ять років роботи в
цьому напрямі керівництво над і як
ви знаєте у нас вперше це geode землі
і спрямовано називається
я по саміт натомість в Україні і це теж
дуже гарний такий знак ось тут мені
кажуть що дуже багато питань я вам
обіцяю даю слово що обов'язково на все
відповім але не кажуть що їм додому час і
приймеш тому я на сьогодні прощаюсь
сподіватимемося що це перший такий
розумний і я постараюся окрім телепрограм
ще й ось такий ось спілкування з вами
до побачення скоринки вони самі